how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how do I
get in on the contrary everything I know
no buttresses the points that I've been
making throughout which is essentially
that there's very much more to this than
meets the eye or perhaps very much less
to this than meets the eye would be a
better way of putting it my current
thinking on this [ __ ] case is that it
can be compared to a drug deal gone
wrong I'm perfectly sure that these two
Russians that were identified by the
police are involved in the case I don't
believe for one minute and never half
that they came to see Salisbury
Cathedral and Stonehenge but were put
off by the slush I never believed that
for a second so I'm perfectly sure that
these two Russians were in contact
either with the scribbles or with people
who were in contact with the scribbles I
think they came to Salisbury for that
purpose but I don't believe for a minute
that they are Russian intelligence
agents if they are then God helped the
Russian people if that's the caliber of
Russian intelligence these days were
asked to believe that these two men were
banging prostitutes and smoking drugs in
a flea pit hotel in East London the
night before an assassination attempt
lead
Nava choc in their hotel room but so
scarcely that the police didn't even
tell the hotel yeah nevermind the staff
and the guests that have been staying
there ever since the police knew on May
the 7th that there were traces of what
they're calling Nava choc in that hotel
were asked to believe that two people
under their own names flew directly to
and from Moscow and made no attempt to
cover their identities and did seem to
be seeking out cCTC CCTV cameras to grin
at in a comedy parade of how not to do
intelligence work so I absolutely do not
believe that these two people are
Russian intelligence agents and I do not
believe that the Russian state had any
motive at all for carrying out such a
crime at that time
well it could be anything there could be
working for other intelligence services
but it's much more likely that they're
involved in some criminal activity I
believe they were criminals and I
believe the secret of this whole case
lies in the undergrowth of Russian
oligarch the the overlap between Russian
oligarch politics and crime
no no not on my principal reason for not
believing it is the old legal adage cui
bono who benefits who benefited from
this crime at that time a hundred days
exactly before the beginning of the
world cup into which Russia had invested
billions and risked the entire public
relations of the world cup a few days
before Putin's presidential election and
when Russia was already facing a raft of
international sanctions and ostracism it
simply doesn't benefit Russia to carry
out such a crime at that time well you
know you can't have it both ways the
West paints Putin as a mephistopheles a
wizard and Grand Wizard Bergling the
elections in the United States
rigging brexit trying to rig the
Scottish referendum rigging the
political situation in Catalonia you
can't have it both ways you can't say
he's mephistopheles but he's an idiot
he's either one or the other it can be
both a very smart operator one of the
smartest in the world today ten times
smarter than the American president or
the British Prime Minister for that
matter I believe he acts in Russia's
interests and it was not in Russia's
interests to carry out the scribble
affair if the hidden point and your
question is do I support him no I don't
if I'd be not Russian I wouldn't devote
it for him
but I do support many of the foreign
policy stances that he has taken
particularly in Syria where he has been
instrumental in defeating Isis and
al-qaeda and the alphabet soup of
Islamist extremism in the Middle East
which i think is
necessary but not sufficient condition
for stability peace progress in that
area well the primary responsibility for
those actions lies with those who sent
and paid for and armed the jihadists to
enter these areas occupy them torture
other people crucify them literally cut
their heads off and cut the heads off
any journalists who turned up to see
what was going on there's a state of
total war in Sorrell there has been and
Isis and al-qaeda have to be defeated
that's the view that Britain and America
took in Mosul in Iraq which they
completely leveled killing tens of
thousands of civilians it's funny that
nobody ever asks me about that they only
asked me about civilian casualties in
Syria
I would have voted for the candidate of
the Communist Party because I'm a
socialist I believe that Putin's
government is far too soft on the rich
and powerful in Russia and does far too
little for the broad mass all the people
Putin has lifted living standards in
Russia by one and a half times in his
period in office in other words everyone
in Russia is a hundred and fifty percent
better off than they were before he came
to power but far too little has been
done to redistribute Russia's wealth
especially in the period of a high oil
price which is getting quite high again
and therefore I would have voted for the
candidate closest to my political views
and that would have been the Communist
Party candidate
what crimes is russia committed I first
of all Russia didn't invade Crimea the
Crimean people voted overwhelmingly to
rejoin Russia the emphasis being on
rejoin and the international community
should recognize that and they will and
before not very much longer also so I
don't regard that as a crime if you've
got any other examples give me one well
the government the legitimate government
of the Ukraine was overthrown by force
Western coordinated financed organized
force the Parliament was set on fire
the president was chased from the
country and the first act of the coup
authorities in Kiev was to delegitimize
the language of 40% of the country
namely the Russian language the Ukraine
has said upon a course of civil war
against the provinces which are
russian-speaking culturally Russia some
cases actual Russian nationals and the
responsibility for the situation in the
Ukraine lies with the coup authorities
in Kiev and their fascist base literally
fascist I mean people who literally
worship fascist collaborators who
murdered massacred Jews in the Ukraine
even before the SS arrived so I'm sorry
if you expect me to have any sympathy
with the cool authorities in Kiev I
simply don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I already that's a rather
tendentious way of putting it I already
worked out where you're coming from by
your second question and now at least
you're being frank and open the short
answer to your question is no Russia's
entitled to stop importing Georgian wine
just like Georgia's entitled to stop
importing Russian Goods and both have
done so so I simply don't accept your
premise I don't believe that Russia is a
malign actor in Georgia
I believe that Georgian nationalism
fanaticism is the malign actor there I'm
not a nationalist and however sweet your
entreaties you'll never entice me there
national independence is one thing
chauvinism xenophobia
is quite another and Ukrainian
nationalism and Georgian nationalism for
that matter are xenophobic chauvinistic
anti-russian you mustn't define your
national ism with reference to other
people that's why I'm against Scottish
nationalism for example because it is
essentially defining Scotland by a
dislike of England and this happens when
small countries are next to big
countries
no I just I'm just not with you on your
premise no no my flag is red and it's a
worldwide flag I don't support any
nationalism anywhere yeah in Syria to
defeat Islamic fundamentalism yeah that
has nothing to do with nationalism
that's internationalism
this game in the game in the wake of
xenophobic chauvinistic and at least
partly fascistic coup in Kiev the people
in eastern Ukraine and the people in
Crimea I'm not going to live under
Ukrainian xenophobic government with a
fascist base on the streets they're just
not going to and they didn't and they
haven't and they never will it's very
far from tiny the fascist militarized
base of Ukrainian nationalism is well
charted as is their anti-semitism as is
their blatant racism so you'll find no
sympathy from me for that I'm afraid no
matter how many times you ask the same
question
more imperialist ideas are promoted by
the Russian government
as I say I don't know how many times
you're gonna ask the same question but
I'm as patient as you are and the answer
is no thank you very much
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in aaaggghhh